dylan cease going about for his 27th
start of the year he's looking for his
11th win his era has sunk below four a
lot of strikeouts 177 of them in 137 and
and two-thirds
we're taking a first-hand true vaughan
playing his natural position and looking
very natural doing so one gone ortega is
a deadpool hitter and so it was wise of
andrew to be close to the bag first base
pretty much like third base it's not
necessarily speed but it's first step
quickness frank schwendell 3-2 struck
him out a high slider and two gone half
a switch hitter hitting left-handed the
2-2 calls make three
he just painted 99 on the outside corner
the professor kyle hendricks out on the
mound we've seen it before many times
sink or change up four-seam fastball
which he's throwing a lot more
this season in the curve ball sprinkles
those in and he'll face cesar hernandez
to lead it off for the white sox
and that one on the inside corner got
him looking hernandez didn't like the
call from sean barber and here is luis
robert
robert just massacres this ball there is
no chance it is gone
that's a 26 home run he's given up this
year we told you that the hitting was
there and the power will come well for
luis the power is going to start to come
from here on out abreu dunks one into
right and now it's
jimenez
on the ground hit hard flagged down by
wisdom goes to second for one duffy onto
first and that's a double play leadoff
walks
walk and wisdom is on with duffy coming
up
on the ground second base cesar laori
double play
four to six to three well turned by a
middle infield that doesn't know each
other very well jason hayward will check
in he's had a good series here's the
pitch ground ball backhanded by lamb the
third baseman at the shortstop position
brandol who had eight runs batted in on
friday
and a swing and a miss hendricks carves
him up two down gotta have room with the
fastball and then doubled up on the brit
on the change up here two out single for
vaughn white sox lead one to nothing and
now brian goodwin the batter pitched a
goodwin and a fly ball out in the deep
left
hat back it's gone
and opposite field two run homer
brian goodwin and it's three-nothing
oh it's a gusty day and bluster from
brian goodwin for a three-nothing lead
alfonso rivas now making his big league
debut he played collegiately at the
university of arizona in tucson he's
been playing with triple a iowa this
season his first major league at-bat he
hits a ground ball in the center field
of base hit
welcome to the big leagues alfonso rivas
that didn't take long first pitch
swinging sharp ground ball between the
second baseman hernandez and the bag
and a smiling alfonso rivas is at first
base rivas aboard and here is alcantara
one and two for alcantra and he struck
him out there's a slider away third
strikeout for cease lead off singles
cesar hernandez luis robert will
step in there's a ground ball to third
wisdom to second the ball is turned by
duffy to first double play five four
three
twin killing hendricks good pitch in on
the hands of luis roberts
has given up one hit through three he's
got a three-nothing lead frank swindell
struck out in the first inning
this one lifted into the air left field
pretty well struck ximena is at the wall
and it's gone
here in the schwinde city frank goes
yard 3-1
number six for schwendell it's now a
three to one ball game socks lead by two
ian hat
got him swinging on the curveball
yes monty to first one gone one and two
for wisdom
he got him fastball i don't know what he
was looking for but i think he got a
fastball that
absolutely fooled him so with two outs
of walk and then a single here comes
austin
call
strike three
slider on the outside corner three
strikeouts in the inning
hanzo rivas leading things off for the
cubs
slashes that one the other way fair ball
down the line and then it bangs off the
sidewall reboss into second and he's got
a double
well that's a nice way to start your big
league career two for two with a
single and a double sergio alcantara one
two swing and a miss on a fastball he
finally gets alcantara for his seventh
strikeout that's out number one the
batter is ortega
strike three on a slider so for dylan
sees the last five outs of the game have
been strikeouts this is perfect because
this looked like a strike in the middle
of the zone for a long time two down
after rivas doubled c struck out
alcantara and he just fanned ortega
pitch on the way swinging a miss
on a high slider
nine strikeouts for dylan cease through
five he had to work hard in that inning
two walks in the inning for kyle
hendricks very rare
he hit him
well there's no way in the world that he
wanted to hit him with a brillo coming
up next and what a brave has done to the
cubs and notably to hendrix yeah loaded
without a hit well you know it's the
last thing in the world he wanted to do
load the bases for this guy here the sox
fans chanting mvp and abreu in the air
out into deep center and
it's over the head of ortega
goodwin scores
hernandez is in
it is a double
that is huge it's five to one that's why
i didn't want that guy up there he owns
him and he's an rbi king and he's over
100 on the year yes he is absolute
missile and now eloy jimenez
to right field hayward back eloy jimenez
continues
to torture come pitching eloy jimenez
has so much power that he doesn't really
have to put a charge into it he just
flicked it the other way and
even into the wind it went out of the
ballpark so david ross comes out taking
his ace out of the ball game after
giving up eight big ones here today adam
morgan on for the 25th time runner at
first two outs grand all hitting right
handed
yasmani launches right field this is out
of here
good to see 24 back in the lineup good
to see the power from both sides of the
plate grand doll with a blast two-run
homer 10-1 dylan
is back out to start the sixth inning
payoff pitch strike three
last seven outs for cease have been
strikeouts and he's got ten of them
three and two
sliders strike three
and dylan sees
who normally is stoic
just gave a little
well look wisdom's had a great series
and
that one caught the bottom part of the
zone good call by sean barber that time
11 strikeouts for cease now duffy duffy
makes contact and is slicing liner right
center and it's run down by louise
robert the waist high catch on the move
and that
certainly will be it for dylan c six
strong innings so garcia now at second
two outs in the inning and now luis
robert
robert drive left field luis robert does
it one more time
oh you said the power was coming
in spades today a dozen for the sox
robert with a two-homer day and it's
12-1
it's his second career multi-homer game
so the sox have a chance for even more
with three on and one out
[Applause]
right side
duffy and romine and that will be that
sox get another run on an rbi from brian
goodwin lamb scores and it's 13-1 liam
hendricks on to pick up an inning with
the off day tomorrow you don't want him
to spend too many days away from that
mom
he got him
liam hendricks with a primal scream
even before the punch out by barber two
outs
oh and two
struck him out
three pitches and a farewell for liam
hendricks 13-1 your final score in a
seven-run inning